[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est de plus en plus beaux gosses
parce que vous voyez pas souvent c'est
pour ça que vous dites ça ne devrait pas
des vrais talents mais je plaisante ne
sommes les gens sont possesseurs yanji
parce que je le dis aux gens c'est le
seul à la réunion le matin c'est le seul
qui peut pas venir il faut qu'on le
fasse appeler pour les mener dans la
région auquel chaque pas te regardent
ils ou 6 heures et va te descendre
donc je suis timide c'est pour ça que la
mêlée ça file un melon ah non mais lui
l'a prénommé mais c'est quelque chose de
fou alors écouter aujourd'hui c'est ma
85e avec vous
85 le cinquième mois ça combien tiempo
doc moi tous les jours c'est la première
tu as l'électricité chez toi j'ai mis
l'eau chaude aujourd'hui je vois que les
couleurs en fait tu tu ne les vois pas
je suis habillé tout seul
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors comme je parlais chiffres j'ai
envie qu'on commence directement avec le
point sur ceux qui parlent le plus ou le
moins dans tout sport bien sûr c'est
n'oubliez pas de prendre la parole c'est
parti bébé
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans votre nouveau
classement de n'oublier pas de pour ma
part je m'emballe est totalement se fait
plaisir
cette semaine on d'imposition retrouve
avec seulement 36 de parole celui des
tellement écolo qui ne prend qu'une
douche pas moins
christophe carrière l'express s'apprête
à la tête tu es vieux qu on donnait
position on retrouve celle qui n'est
intervenue que quand on propose cette
semaine mais vous allez voir que c'est
très dur pour elle de prendre la parole
lundi isabelle morini-bosc tous les
rouges se retrouver demain vous parlerai
demain on lui casse mon c'est toujours
la baston entre nos deux champions est
bien la deuxième place un autre ou celui
qui est le meilleur imitateur de 65
interventions pour jean-michel mais
angie sauter des classes avec laquelle
je souhaitais pas malade et ps je vois
les profs ans les classes et il reste à
la première place alors qu'il n'a même
pas levé toutes les émissions cette
semaine
pourquoi pas des zizis sur les bas du
zizi à tant de plaisir cette dizaine de
feux sont dits prise de parole pour me
tuer il ya de la rocky si tu veux venir
faire un selphy avec de leurs mots ou
venir le vent en coulisses tu viens
quand tu veux ça t'intéresse
ce même projet ne fait pas beaucoup de
gens
l'appel de lino nous manque alors sage
et qui nous est en vacances scolaires et
que forcément il y des meufs tout ça
donc il n'est pas libre avec son père
l'appelle mais quand les vacances
scolaires il n'a pas le temps d'appeler
sera non taillés sur des bas il était
avec ivoire sans rigoler samedi il avait
une soirée halloween il est rentré il
est rentré à 11 heures du soir là cet
après midi était qu une meuf a été voir
une comédie musicale mais dès qu'elle
repart donc à quoi il a 7 ans mais il
est déjà sur des balles de peinture
il emprunte une baleine le flanc de 3e
année de médecine à s'intégrer mais
ouais mon vieux et ouais alors allons
parvenir y aille parce que là ils
m'appellent plus lent ce moment je pense
qu'il a voilà il est pas en quoi il est
pas de nom je vous le dis et pas devant
elle à dubaï dans l'allée mais vous
savez il est ou non là bas là je sais
par mon avis dans il nous est pas encore
entré les 18h48 c'est dans ces bas il a
7 ans il fait sa vie menacée buenos
aires est ce juste sur l'autoroute on
sait pas il s'amuse
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas compris a pas eu non plus vous
verriez le petit jean michel qui va
revenir vous allez voir il fait que ça
tout le temps très bien à la journée une
nouvelle recrue depuis hier dont je suis
fan depuis toujours il est aussi dans la
grande d'arca et bientôt j'espère dans
balances ton post c'est fabien le cow
boy le club l'ami des stars franchement
il est magnifique et bravo une start-up
le blouson des prix s il est très beau
celui-là tu d'accueil pour la deuxième
émission quoi cela tu le mets toujours
pour tes deuxième émission so blouson
ouais merci merci sa maman te dérange
non non non mais je me laisse un défaut
de la marque d'amiante ou ty amenant
même panonceau thébaux et oui il a fait
une émission il sait que dans la parler
bien sûr et là moi j'ai pas la grande
marque a surtout parce que fabien
lecoeuvre c'est le bernard montiel blanc
c la baisse est un billard
[Applaudissements]
fabiano cas où ils peut-on raconter des
trucs qui te sont arrivés lors qu'il
irait même pas vécu c'est ça qui est
formidable
il donne tout le temps des dates sur la
vie des saints et personne ne vérifie
jamais si les dates sont bonnes et bat
laurent baffie dans la vente d'art cas
et l'on peut déjà plus des dates le pot
fabien lecoeuvre en a pris tellement
qu'à la race samedi qu'on va désormais
l'appeler fabien le pauvre
[Musique]
réellement on a connu pour la première
fois le visage norris laffont quelqu'un
lui a demandé quelque chose ça fait déjà
un piano d'europe 3 allez pas vous
n'êtes pas connu vous êtes projet de 78
et on se retrouvait comme tiger d'al
nadheer retrouver sa toute première
émission heuel janvier 70
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme si j'allais connu toute ma
vie en un instant et c'est resté comme
ça tout le temps en 1984 comme ils
entendent pas seulement des deux îles à
vos dossiers de nouveaux artistes font
ne connais pas mais avec douchez
attendait en plateau on attendait avec
mehdi mitchell maison
le rockeur la chine
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
di michele franchement tu es très bon ah
ouais tu as toi
wesh open forme non quand tu veux la
prochaine fois je vais vers eddy
mitchell je pense qu'il va m'en parler
allez jean michel alors jean-michel mais
on est pas qu un fayot ce serait
réducteur de dire ça non c'est aussi un
cancre mais un camp qui veut malgré tout
faire plaisir à son prof ou cyril ils
essaient de vous faire rire par tous les
moyens parfois il est trahi par sa
bouche mais il est surtout trahi par son
humour comme d'habitude regardez bien sa
tête de dépressif un peu comme à
l'instant quand il prend des fours
c'est le retour du petit jean michel le
petit jean michel tente encore une fois
de faire rire son professeur mais ça ne
fonctionne toujours pas en beauce et tu
racontes rôle à jouer at il était dans
ma classe à la balle est tombée
boukistan outréaux
enfin c'est moi la 312 oui bonjour est
ce que vous avez vu un poil de l'udc
dans la le petit jean michel essaye
alors de fermer des invités wilson
fonctionne pas non content avec toutes
mes sets je vais tout s'entend bien
c'est vrai que dans ces pays on sait pas
d accès
[Musique]
et vous voulez devenir avocate oui c'est
ça j'ai fait un endroit et en fait ça
[Musique]
le petit jean michel et tone élèves
tellement intelligent que son cerveau va
plus vite que ça bouge alors on ne
comprend pas forcément ce qu'il dit
parce qu'il faut voir la salle tu vois
avec le tiroir et non je jouais vraiment
mais très salée on est à fond
[Musique]
ce n'est pas un invité je sais mais pour
moi il est tout le temps à tout le temps
voilà ce que je sais je sais mais
j'adore tellement alors chaque jeudi
benoît s'est invitée alors chaque jeudi
je n'aurais jamais balances ton poste
l'émission car sans forme et cyril
hanouna ans david pujadas mais avec 94
cm de plus qu'une image que j'ai mise
excusez moi il ya une image que j'ai
mise de côté qui concerne jean messia à
un membre du rassemblement national et
le gars quand il est ému c'était fait
défoncer tout l'émission par tout le
monde et notamment par vous un tout
petit peu mais comme vous êtes sympas à
la fin de balance en pause pour rigoler
vous le dit
allez viens participer un jour la grande
dar k le problème c'est que j'en ai
c'est et ultra chaud pour venir donc
quand il vous répond qu'il est d'accord
on voit votre lettre que vous regrettez
votre proposition
c'est nouveau et zumba immédiatement
[Musique]
bravo est devenu franchement pays voilà
peu ou bien il fait la grande barque
avec moi
vous
non
alors si la semaine et a beaucoup de
talent mais pas l'incroyable talent de
garder un secret l'année dernière nous
avait avoué ici que france télévisions
avait contacté mardi dernier quand vous
l'avez demandé s'il y aurait une saison
d'incroyable talent all star et pas les
gagnants des saisons précédentes
il se doute pas qu'il va tomber non pas
sur un enquêteur mais sur deux enquêteur
hors pair qui ont lui faire cracher le
morceau
c'est un nouvel épisode ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'a pas vu de
l'inspecteur la bavure
[Musique]
quand il s'agit de m6 isabelle morini
bosc est à fond et c'est eric antoine
qui ont fait les frais le futur oui
incroyable talent spécial champions oui
parce qu'il va y avoir un spectacle
champion bat hélicon thuan a les yeux
dans le lapin pris dans la lumière des
phares
il sait qu'il vient de tomber dans un
piège
je n'ai pas à me parler de cette
information a le droit de parler de
cette information
ce n'est pas une réponse satisfaisante
pour l'inspecteur la bavure qui va
cuisiner le suspect le patron d'm6
l'inspecteur la bavure fait utilisation
de sa spécialité
l'intimidation ça que les mecs m'ont dit
je ne parle pas de ça et il est
invivable arrêté eric antoine un peu
pour sa place mais prise en tenailles
entre l'inspecteur la bavure et sa
partenaire bientôt à la retraite
il commence on est en train de
travailler sur un programme spin off
d'un capital en ce moment en effet au
cavalière est en train de préparer un
truc sur une méchante haut avec des
anciens candidats
encore une fois est qu'antoine est passé
à table combat canadiens en fait vous ne
faites jamais encore une enquête
rondement menée par l'inspecteur la
bavure mais le trophée le plus attendu
de toute la tva à 16
vous allez connaître celui qui a le plus
tacler ses collègues ces derniers jours
le trophée du sale bâtard dans le tarn à
16 fois d'affilée que vous remportez
c'est le meur alors musique de suspense
cyril est ce que perdre votre titre de
tarbes à bas serait un véritable
camouflet journée très triste voyez je
dois vous dire que cette semaine pour la
première fois c'était très serré entre
le 1er et le 2ème minute que 250 e tacle
d'écart ah ouais quand même
quand même ça s'est joué à ça le 17e
karmapa est donc
[Applaudissements]
non
franchement je pense qu'il faut voir
tout de suite les choses au niveau
totalement jeudi honshu bad va te faire
[ __ ]
[Rires]
c'est voué castaldi j'ai fait je vais à
cause de vous dire quand on ressemble au
troisième round up
chez le rat d'elton john une voix off un
peu de beauté vraiment c'est un des
petits plus plus de franchisés d'une
analyse médias ton et c'est tout il n'y
a pas d'autres talents mois le maire
s'était cascadeur vous avez pas voulu
ah ouais ouais bah c'est pas casto de la
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tumeur était comme ça vous ferait du
bien souvent une personne dont tout le
monde se fout c'est comme dans l'édition
alors attention c'est pas parce que dans
le titre c'est incroyable talent qu'on
va en voir forcément comme on l'a par
exemple l'histoire carrière c'est pour
ça qu'il a une carrière
[Rires]
excusez-moi série après le ping pong
c'est pas la semaine vous avez peut-être
notamment gagné seulement deux échecs
bah vous en avez eu des échecs pourtant
vous êtes toujours à la télé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]